miles how many times did you get punched
in the face over one less than a hundred
okay yeah I couldn't tell you what was
it like the first time versus the
hundredth the first time shocking second
they're not shocking but first times
like yeah it's yes we'll say a little
shocking and then after that it's like
okay now I'm okay you got yours I'm
gonna give you mine okay did you see
yourself in Vinnie Paz what do you mean
weird they're parts of Vinnie passes
life in terms of his rise and then
stalled out for a little bit with the
accident that reminded you of anything
in your own life or baby well I mean I
think with Vinnie Vinnie had his family
support Vinnie also his sport was boxing
my sport was baseball baseball was
something that you know I remember even
in high school I was doing as a freshman
I would be the guy going to two days
with the seniors ROG I'd go to high
school at a you know five thirty and run
laps and do all that stuff like if I had
the talent and baseball that's something
I would have given everything to I think
sports for me just the discipline and
kind of the you know the ethics of the
games it was something that I really
associated with you said that you want
to be part of films that affect people
how do you feel that a Vinnie pass a
story will affect viewers oh well I
think it's you know it's the greatest
comeback in sports but you know you
could even get rid of the word sports
it's just an incredible comeback here's
a guy who faced really like impossible
odds and is the first person to ever do
that and I just think that it's a you
know it's inspiring story that's gonna
you know if people want to they can take
what he did and you know connected to
their own life and if they're feeling
tired they feel like they can't do it
and oh man it's just so hard well look
at what he did like how hard is that and
he still did it so like what are you
gonna complain about we talked about
striving for greatness and the isolation
I know you've talked about you enjoy
Kobe Bryant's documentary believe yeah
yeah yeah that's why I was gonna talk
yeah I was a good investor what's gonna
relate to Kobe and you know and he's
documentary talked about that like if
you really want to be great at something
you know maybe you can't be the best
friend or the best brother or the best
son or the best you know whenever like
it's uh you know that quest for
greatness it is it's gonna be a selfish
journey but if you look you'll get one
chance at this life so if you really
want to give everything to something
then it's gonna be yeah it is gonna be
an isolated journey and you just have to
be comfortable with you know other areas
other of your life being sacrificed for
that how are you dealing with that these
days because so many things are coming
your way
opportunities notoriety well God's good
I have good balance you know I have you
know I have a good family I've great
friends that I've known since I was like
14 15 I don't have to worry about how's
this guy gonna screw me over whatever
it's like now I've known these guys more
than half my life you know I've got a
great professional team of people around
me I've got a good girl like it's all um
I don't know I got enough things to kind
of still make me feel like myself
excellent thank you